I'm so pleased that you're here this
afternoon I'm introducing myself
and for those of you who don't know me
or know me only as Dean I have been
studying the ancient Maya for 40 years
and I've been working on the particular
project of Bonampak for the past 17 and
when finally this past summer the 17
years of research on Bonampak were
published in a volume that I have
described as a useful doorstop to some
of you I was saying to those who were in
my office in in SSS that I was looking
out and seeing monkeys scampering away
across the tops of Kirtland Hall because
they had finally escaped from my back
it's such a great pleasure to be able to
talk to you about this subject because
in fact there is nothing I love more
than talking about the murals of bonham
puck that's an incredible subject and
let me just quickly orient you you can
follow the red arrow where we will you
find both Bonampak and Yasha chil'en
places I will be referring to today
other arrows point to places in my world
that may be more familiar to you from
Palenque on the left to Tulum and Koba
on the in the upper right hand corner
but this is the map and we skip from it
onto the paintings of Bonampak and it is
these luminous amazing paintings the
most extensive complete and
extraordinary paintings of the ancient
Maya world truly in their completeness
the most extraordinary paintings of the
ancient new world all together that draw
us here today and have drawn me back to
this topic time and again you see them
painted here inside this small temple
painted just at the end of the eighth
century and to give you a tiny bit of
historical context the ancient Maya
living in the rainforest in that map I
just showed you thrived throughout the
first
millennium ad and when we come to this
period at the end of the eighth century
the beginning of the ninth we're looking
at what is typically known among
anthropologists as the great classic
Maya collapse in a city such as Palenque
T called urban park will be abandoned
around the Year 800 or shortly
thereafter
or perhaps shortly before up until that
moment we have Anna markable kind of
fine-grained his brain history for that
period and then afterwards we find that
in fact we think of it more in
archeological terms periods in eras
rather than in days weeks moments
Bonaparte has a particular Yale quality
to its story and you see it here when
you look at Giles Healey 24s a graduate
of the chef school who's had spent the
Second World War
living in the tropical rainforest hoping
to make a great discovery he had this
idea that he would find a big one at
some point that he would make a
discovery that would be transforming to
the world in 1929 he had been the first
person to bring back to the United
States or to a European setting a an
amount quality of kirari that would be
possible to medicalize and it would not
be Healy himself although a chemical
engineer who would be able to do this
but as a scientist in Britain on the eve
of the Second World War who would do so
nevertheless he had this idea that there
were discoveries that could be made and
that would transform the world but I
also have to add about Healy is that if
we think of him in good early
twentieth-century terms perhaps the word
bounder or CAD come to mind because it
turns out that he would Ted off on these
rainforests escapades in
South America or in Mexico or in
Guatemala just in fact when he had a
marriage that needed to be taken apart
and on the same day that he arrived from
Venezuela with this remarkable amount of
kirari on the front page of the New York
Times his divorce was unfolding on the
pages within a nasty reno divorce he
made this discovery in 1946 we may think
of him and certainly the Mexicans as
they characterized this they imagined
him as a Yalie who had a silver spoon in
his mouth I show you the family junk
store from third Avenue a rather
legendary place photographed by Berenice
Abbott with the exceptional quantity of
things that were in the store you can
only imagine how different he was from
the Hayes and Whitney's of his day when
the family store by the way was finally
all the contents of it auction doff in
1939 there were two young auctioneers
mr. Park and mr. Burnett who bought the
entire contents sold them over three
days at a sale in Long Island and if
there are any art historians in the room
you will know that Parke Bernet
was the foundational auction house that
led eventually to Sotheby's what was in
this junk shop was an amazing collection
of things and so Giles Healy had grown
up around strange and interesting things
this is Giles back at Bonampak
in 1980 when he visited it for the last
time shortly before his death and the
only time after 1947 when he had
returned there after making the
discovery in 1946 it was a kind of
discovery that would make the front
would make the pages of Life magazine
you're drawn to Ricardo Montalban on the
cover of it and you hear the notes of
The Love Boat in your mind
uh Giles Heelys discovery was riveting
and when he found himself in 1946 in
this remarkable place where he had hired
the unnamed Lakhan tone guy named John
Moore who's here with him in this life
magazine photo when he had when John
bore had suddenly come upon these
paintings which the Maya who lived in
this region themselves did not know when
he saw these paintings he knew
immediately their import he knew that
there had been scraps of paintings found
high and dry vaults in Maya buildings he
knew that there had been scraps of
paintings that had been revealed under
archaeological rubble but he knew that
there had never been an extraordinary
and complete program before so when he
got back to the place in 1946 from which
you could make what was called a trunk
phone call he called the nerve center of
Maya studies in the world at that moment
he called Washington did not call Mexico
City
setting up generations of bad blood
between Mexican archaeologists and
American archaeologists about who owned
the intellectual property of this site
in fact it was so desperate that there
was one Danish archeologist living in
Mexico who termed what would become a
terrible war between the various
archaeological are essentially armed
camps Bonampak itis a kind of disease I
caught one and poked itis but I will
also tell you that my goal has been to
develop the vaccine what was so
astonishing about these paintings was
not only that they were complete they
were full of hieroglyphs they were full
of individuals they were obviously
narrative and figural and exciting to
look at you're looking at a dead captive
here sprawled across steps with another
dead head at his decapitated head his
feet but for one thing they showed the
Maya in a state of dramatic warfare and
there was a widespread belief
at mid-century that in fact the maya had
been unlike any other civilization in
the history of humanity and they had not
in fact been party to the kind of
self-serving occupations that we find
among every civilization in the world
and that the maya had in fact been
rather than being warlike and interested
in themselves in their art had instead
devoted themselves to making works of
art that were all about pure expressions
of time time t IM e not an herb that
they were just peaceful time keepers and
anyone who is i would say unless you
were born after nineteen seventy that
would be the first thing if you knew
anything about the maya you would know
that they were peaceful and so these
paintings which showed something else
were readily and graphically suddenly
seemed to be in contradiction with this
notion what is quite striking is that
most of the scholarly work that came out
at the time of course could not
recognize this and the great british
scholar Sir Eric Thompson who wrote
about the paintings assumed and I will
show you battle scenes here
that if there are scenes of sacrifice
and torture it cannot be that that is
what is being represented it is a
misperception on our part and if there
are people with bleeding hands they must
have dipped their hands in red paint he
also found it astonishing having been
quite certain that there was no reason
the Maya would ever represent women in
art he found it quite disturbing that
there were figures who were obviously
women in these works and the most
impressive of them all a woman we now
know by the lovely name of lady rabbit a
lady rabbit of this of this nameless to
him individual he said what is she doing
here kind of Plain Jane no nonsense club
woman of our era oh you feel the 50's
are alive and well when you look at
Pok all part of the Bonampak disease
there were competitive desires to claim
the dis ownership of the discovery there
was an American draft dodger who had
spent a named originally named Herman
fry from Staunton Ville Illinois became
Carlos Frey perhaps a name adopted by a
recent mayoral candidate in New York
City as well where a series of terrible
tragedies he had come very close to
making the same discovery but had not
just a few months before there was a
great deal of the sense that there had
been a lost city curse he had written
many many letters home beforehand
complaining always to his brother but as
you see underlined in the bottom purple
what a Babbitt you've become if he would
not send him money to help him find the
big one everyone thought that finding
the big one would be their ticket out in
some respects oh did Giles Healy Giles
Healy thought he would make a movie
about bond and puck was a movie he
managed to get his fellow Yalie Vincent
Price to be one of the narrator's of but
it was a movie that went nowhere on the
documentary circuit and in fact Healy
ended up returning from Mexico to Los
Angeles where he had this healing
assistant exotic guy he had this
collection of rare cars from very early
in the 20th century pre-world War one
cars and he used them to Squire the be
b-movie Hollywood set around for many
years before retiring to Big Sur where
he would live next door to Henry Miller
Giles Healy an early subscriber to sex
and drugs and rock and roll
so what do you do about these paintings
well the Americans were very interested
in them the Mexicans were very
interested in both sent teams of
copyists because was thought that this
is the only way that you can actually
study these paintings is by making
copies of them you couldn't really the
rooms were very narrow is so hard to
photograph them it was hard to light
them your generators ran out of juice so
they decided to have a copyists who
would make the this is a life-size
replica that's being held here by one by
the Mexican copyist I was seen by Agata
and these paintings that were half
life-size and you get a sense of that
Here I am the height as I say of a Maya
King five foot three I'm pretty good
until Maya King the tallest Maya King
ever found as five foot eight and must
have been like Abraham Lincoln among in
his rather extraordinary stature the
paintings have a kind of presence in
Mexico that's almost like our image of
Washington Crossing the Delaware you
don't have to know the lights of
painting or ever have seen it in the Met
to nevertheless have this strong sense
of I know what the bottom pot paintings
look like there was a ballet Bonampak
it's been on many postage stamps not
only this one from 1974 and how amusing
actually a couple of years ago when I
was in Mexico City to find that this
Jeep Jeep they make he call was selling
its jeeps using images of the Bonampak
murals around the Jeep on the wall it
seems like a natural thing to see Bonham
Pok as part of advertising and as a very
familiar part of Mexico's visual culture
it has been claimed it's been claimed in
Mexico how do we come then to understand
it some of you I know have already
walked into the pre-columbian room here
just outside us in the gallery today and
know
Bonampak in a half-scale replica is now
on view there one of the rooms so um how
do we put the murals back into the rooms
and understand them in light of their
extremely controlling architectural
setting well here's a here's a start and
we we realize from the very beginning
that one of the challenges is
understanding how you even make such a
program how do you take a set of ideas
and map them so that you are they're
consistent in scale and size of figures
all throughout three rooms what's what's
pretty clear is that at least in the
artists mind if not actually physically
drawn on the wall for the painting here
is not Bonampak but another painting
where they've done their best to scrape
away most of the guideline you can see a
little bit of it so they probably drew
the whole thing out on a grid we often
look at my art and say oh it's just so
convoluted their figures everywhere and
yet the strong quality orthogonal
quality of the grid underpins this and
equally extraordinary is that from room
to room the opinions are the exact same
recipe over large areas of walls and
particularly when we look at these
luminous Blues when a Maya looked at
this luminous blue one of the first
reactions a Maya would have to walk into
room one as we will in just a minute
would be to say oh my gosh really
expensive the same reaction that you
might have walking in to say San Marco
in Venice of wow there is a lot of gold
in here one of those instant senses of
someone has invested a great deal in
this blue has this same value and the
Maya blue was a great invention of the
Maya probably somewhere around three or
four hundred
ad in which they figured out how to fix
indigo into a clay that in using a an
alkaline process a niche tamal process
that's the same one used to turn maize
into a wholesome and healthy masa that
the making this incredibly powerful blue
and in some parts of the murals
particularly in room one not only is it
this great Maya blue but they've ground
into it azurite which comes from the
northern deserts near the border with
the United States and ground as right
into it so that it just sparkles and
pops off the wall we can imagine that
there are whole troops of assistants who
are working alongside the most skilled
artists and who are our artists I'm
showing you examples in color here of
newly discovered wall paintings at the
Maya site of Calakmul in Mexico and then
a detail of a painting on a Maya painted
vase and in fact what you can see here
is the way the hands are drawn is very
similar it's as the wall painters and
vase painters a big question often in
Greek art of are who is who but what we
see at Bonampak is very much that our
painters work in a style of
representation of hands and ears and
details that is very much what we see in
the sculptors at nearby yashi lon so we
seemed to have painters who can also be
carvers on perhaps vice versa when Giles
Healy stepped into the rooms he could
see most of the luminous colors because
the walls were damp they walls the
vaulting had a little bit of a leak
mplet where leak could come through
keeping the walls moist but as the trees
were cut down and the walls were plunged
into heat
and absolute dryness of the heat of the
rainforest dry season day and then the
moisture at night of the the paintings
completely dried out and it was clear
that there was a fairly thick cap of
calcification over the top of the
paintings the calcification dried and
became white
it was calcium carbonate that dripped
through the vaults over the top of the
paintings at the time that the copyists
were working the copyist made a great
discovery they said look rather than use
water to keep these paintings wet let's
use kerosene and they'll stay they'll
stay moist for a long time both of the
copyists working side by side we know
were always smoking and painting with
kerosene and we also know that one was
tippling a lot and just to imagine that
the whole thing didn't go up in smoke at
the time and of course you feel a
certain amount of horror the
conservators whom you see on the right
made it clear that they now needed to
starting around 1960 that it could only
be water that would be used on the walls
and you all feel off thank god water
well here's the story about that water
that water came from basically a swamp
nearby and was full of living organisms
and it turned those walls quickly into a
greased green swamp of living things
that loved eating calcifications and
paint and everything else in the walls
you know the good intentions of that are
just so appalling kerosene in fact had
been prohibiting growth and was a
sterile substance unlike the completely
polluted water that they were using
thus in fact making it ever more
difficult to see the paintings so by the
mid 1980s dried out most of the living
organisms now dead on the walls
nevertheless this is what the paintings
looked like and so the National
Institute of anthropology in Mexico
began a campaign using dental
some of them electric to clean the
paintings and even with the best of
intentions of course there is some loss
and what we find is that although the
paintings have been revealed in all of
their the color glory that nevertheless
actually seeing much some significant
part of the detail that Giles Healy was
able to track to see with infrared film
which was by the way a controlled
material in the nineteen throughout the
40s and 50s so he had very good
connections perhaps to OSS in this
period he was he had taken photographs
with infrared and this gave me and some
colleagues the idea that what we needed
to do
perhaps infrared paintings have been
cleaned
you could truly see them now you could
put a camera right up to them but would
it be possible to be able to recuperate
so much of the information that was in
the infrared and so we using
unfortunately the year before digital
infrared would have been possible this
is actually video infrared where we
grabbed each frame by video and then had
to transfer it to digital the next year
nevertheless we were able to find and
see using infrared so much of the final
black outline for our painters mapped
areas of color and then the most skilled
calligraphic line was added at the very
end along with much of the writing using
every document about Bonampak that had
been made between 1946 and the 1990s
I hired artists to reconstruct Bunim
Park at half scale in that amazing
many of you walked past or perhaps
walked into the TAT
to parlor that was long on Chapel Street
on the second floor above it was an
artist studio where we were busy
reconstructing Bonampak from 1999 to
2003 and it is the fruit of that project
that is now on display in the art
gallery and I'll be leaning on that
reconstruction in many ways as we look
at the paintings now and what an amazing
project the reconstruction has been to
be able to take what we can see and what
we can't see in the color and to be able
to take all of that information and put
it into one powerful visual document you
see it here a little bit unfolded you
wonder why are all those cutouts imagine
that you're looking at the back of the
cereal box and you know get rid of those
white areas and fold things in so that
they're back inside there sharply
vaulted spaces and each room is discrete
one room from the next it is clear in
terms of the narrative that the middle
room this chaotic scene of battle that
you see is the middle slice here refers
to the first event something that
happened back in 785 capped by events in
790 and 791 in rooms 1 and 3 let me take
you into them now it is a time in 7 97
91 and perhaps for about 20 years before
this that Maya art begins to do
something that is just extraordinary in
the history of world art it steps right
through the wall it starts talking right
to you it has this amazing
self-conscious and somewhat staged
equality at it's very very best and it
does some interesting pieces right here
as you're walking in you walk into room
1 this is what you see in front of you
and if you look to your right and your
left and you're looking at the edges of
the vaults
you see these fans and they're flipped
yellow and red they are flipped and
they're around the text they are the
only quotation marks in all of the
native new world they're framing the
words almost as if telling us to speak
them and they take us from a date in 792
a date in 791 they tell us that the last
date the last thing they commemorate is
the dedication of a house perhaps this
very house this building that we are
calling a temple or a palace they are
referring to very specifically as the
house of a particular person as the
house of a ruler named Yahoo Chan Wong
they also tell us that it was a period
of time when there had just been an
installation in office of a particular
individual and unfortunately the text is
gone where his name should be up above
the text you see these incredible
figures over to the right we see the
royal family on the throne they seem to
be the royal family and yet here is one
of the punch lines of the story and that
is that about 25 percent of the texts
are just left as blanks these paintings
these paintings are not finished they
are the very last work at the site you
feel this stage enos this self-awareness
and also the power of things not
finished intentionally or
unintentionally some fascinating little
text here because in front of the royal
family we find that there are bags of
valuable things the most extraordinary
is the 5 x 8 thousand or here in the vie
des amol counting system of chocolate
beans so in a time when money truly did
grow on trees
the chocolate bean was one of the few
standards of exchange in the
pre-columbian world particularly in
Mexico the Spanish after the after the
invasion say well one chocolate bean
we'll get you one tamale so you know we
have a few places where we know mmm how
much is a chocolate being worth we know
that there was a terrible problem with
making fired clay counterfeits of
chocolate beans that looked a lot like
our coffee bean today so they're they're
receiving valuable tribute here and we
look at this representation of what
seems to be the royal family but with no
names written in around them whatsoever
and uh two years ago the Mexican
archaeologists working at the site had
been using a sensing equipment to look
for hollows in any part of the building
and they discovered that the bench in
room 2 was hollow they opened it up they
found this tomb inside it it has no
inscriptions it is impossible to know at
this point exactly who it is but it's a
problematic tomb because although there
is the lower mandible the head of this
individual has been replaced with a pot
this is not typically how the Maya they
they would they would include the head
and so it is it is an interesting
problem of have we had some kind of
terrible thing befall the ruling family
of Bonampak
has the king died you will see in room
two that there is a great battle in
which he claims to be the victor and of
course he is it's back in 795 that was
five years ago that was a setup that was
when everything was going so well they
conquered their enemies they smote them
they in fact had this plan of building
this great new building and
celebrating all of their and celebrating
their victory with this expensive fancy
extravagant display of everything at the
top of at the moment of its greatest
peak and then something happens perhaps
it may be that physical anthropology
will tell us a little bit more well
we'll stay tuned for that
these figures who are standing perhaps
in to be understood in front of the
Thrain wearing these amazing textiles it
does reassure you that it is okay to
wear polka dots with plaids and with
stripes because we see every marvelous
textile design you could possibly
imagine
woven and tie-dyed and embroidered all
on display here of Lords whom my
colleague Steve Houston at Brown likes
to call them walking tribute bundles
perhaps they are paying their taxes
paying their tributes we know that at
least one of them is named as a
messenger a good title for an ambassador
or a tribute payer our royal family
looks out at them you see them here
perhaps by having it back in the vault
you can see it a little bit more clearly
and then I now draw your attention to
what you really see as you walk in when
you walk in this room yes this is going
on up above but what you really see are
these three badly damaged figures right
here and this is ancient damage partly
under the calcifications this damage and
yet the hieroglyphs although a little
fragmentary because they were painted
last and some of that thick black paint
fell off before the calcifications could
preserve them nevertheless the
hieroglyphs not intentionally damaged
but the figures themselves perhaps it
tells us who would have damaged them and
perhaps it tells us that it is not their
names that matter but rather their faces
and they may have been perceived to be
functionally alive and that they had to
have their faces chipped out piece by
piece these three figures are dancers
and we will see them again in these
paintings they are young Lords they all
describe themselves as being young Lords
prominent in the dynasty and it seems
very likely that it's one of these young
Lords who's just been named perhaps this
one in the middle they're all dancing
who has just been named to be the new
successor perhaps that is the moment
that is on unfolding here in front of us
if I speak with some tentativeness it's
because we can't have just one simple
story for the bottom part paintings
there are those who commissioned these
paintings those who executed those these
paintings and there are stories that
seem to be erupting that are not
necessarily the stories that they
intended to tell we'll see that a little
more clearly in room two but it's why
there are more than just the stories
that were intentionally commissioned
here our three dancers stand at the
middle so if you again you're imagining
yourself walking into room one and by
the way now you can see that there's
carved lintel over the doorway there's
this built-in bench with this fancy step
fret design you walk in you see these
figures and by the way that height of
that doorway it is exactly my height
without shoes on so if I'm wearing one
of these glamorous costumes I better get
down and be reverent as I step into this
room and as I step into this room I
block all viewing of it there is no
source of natural light torches were
never used in this space how did they
see it you may well ask and it seems
it's quite well illuminated first thing
in the morning this is morning light is
what comes through the doors
and as you walk into the room you walk
in through this doorway and there were
curtain ties here and in fact the Maya
had curtain ties on the outside of this
building as well it must have been
wrapped up like a Christos Christo
project because the Maya seem to have
been trying to preserve it knowing how
that in a world where you get a hundred
inches of rain a year that to be able to
save paintings against the ravages of
time
would take active engagement on their
part as you walk in through the door you
find yourself accompanied out jumping as
part of the procession that either goes
to the right or the left to the left we
have this marvelous musicians and these
costumed characters who are about to
perform to the right we have individuals
named as regional governors here's a
huge composite of infra-red that my
colleagues and I generated I just want
you to see the kind of crisp detail that
informs then the same area in color and
then to turn it in to the reconstruction
as the as this procession of musicians
unfolds the Maya are trying to do
interesting things in this painting look
at our maracas players and you begin to
feel that time is almost elapsing in
front of you did the Maya who used paper
for everything and who loved the idea of
time elapsing after all I told you they
were thought to have been timekeepers
while they were timekeepers but all
timekeeping had a purpose were they in
fact even able to imagine something like
a flip book I say that to you without
really without irony because at the time
of the Spanish invasion one of the
things the Spanish complained about is
how people in the new world
waste paper all the time our musicians
here playing maracas behind them a
drummer standing apart from them and
turtle shells that are being played with
deer antlers this is what the painting
looked like in 1963 it's always good to
kind of calibrate and see it as painting
if we look at our drummer we look at a
detail of some of our maraca players
they're also said to be singers so they
are filling this room was sound and our
drummer takes his hands off the skin you
feel sound being lifted into the space
he's standing still he's sure not moving
with that big drum they're all dancing
around him very much as we see in 16th
century manuscripts made after the
Spanish invasion or on Maya pots where
music is always going in a circle
dancers and musicians always circling
round and around often counterclockwise
on the other side our regional governors
are in these extraordinary expressions
of turning around talking to one another
when when are we ever going to get our
turn Oh howdy as this is excuse me while
I light up a cigarette Oh
turns out look cigarette posture really
yes this is how you this is how you
smoke a cigarette of course seiga is the
Maya word for a tobacco and the products
made of it you hear the word and at the
time of the Spanish invasion traders
from the Maya region sold big old
stogies in bundles of 20 up in Mexico
City you tell me one other product that
has survived to be counted in the vial
counting system I dare you to find one
how it is that the product and its sale
in twenties has survived so long you
step out of room one and this
architectural plan is pretty unusual and
seems perhaps
have been invented to maximize wall
space how can I most how can I use wall
space to maximize the telling of a story
but it also means that we have this kind
of control of the viewer you've been in
this semi darkened space you step out
you step into room two and you are
looking into a model where you can see
that the built-in bench and you step
into this room of battle and my friend
Sir Eric Thompson whom I mentioned
earlier about the plain-jane Club woman
thing he said it's a little raid am i I
didn't have war so this must be a little
raid but in fact it is one of the great
battle paintings in all of all of art
history you see this it unfolds across
three walls and it includes figures who
repeat from place to place figures who
straddle particular parts of going from
one wall to another figures where in one
case a hand reaches out of a scene it
doesn't belong in and touches another
this violation of the wall the notion
that painting is artifice it's easy to
look at these paintings and say well
it's a documentary photograph the Maya
had war we all get that now but in fact
it's all about artifice part of the
artifice here is time again that is
unfolding the battle starts at the far
left trumpets or blare trumpets blare we
come to this little vignette here in the
center where this captive actually seems
to fly right out of the scene if you
stand in that room he's feet peal in
your face and then captives along the
bottom edge of the battle scene are
trussed up two or three victorious
warriors sometimes four or five all
ganging up on individuals to strip them
of their finery and bring them tie them
up and bring them to some
their location watching it all up above
our ancestor figures ancestors in even
the captives of ancestors as though they
live on in the stars and if we go back
to the color here I will simply say that
there's no azurite ground into the blue
here but rather carbon to make it dark
and potent perhaps dawn
perhaps dusk if you sit on the bench you
sit on top of the captives you're part
of it you're now a victor you sit on
someone whose fingernails perhaps had
been pulled his lips have been trimmed
his fingers pulled out of joint this is
where you are you sit on them and if you
sit on them you then look back at the
door through which you walked you walk
through turn around and this is what you
see and it's often held up as the
greatest of all the walls in the
Bonaparte paintings I will say this for
it it has a lot of paint on it and it
feels exquisitely finished
unlike most portions of the paintings
there's there's nothing here that's
obviously undone in fact there are
things that are redone we find that some
of the headdresses have two or three
different headdresses that were painting
as though their gosh tried to get it
right or did in fact this victorious
warrior earned while the painting was
being under was under construction even
earned some new trophy that merited some
new kind of head representation up above
here you see the starry heavens and if
you look at far right you see these
three designs on the back of a turtle
these are the three bright stars that we
read as the belt of Orion and which
today if you're in the Maya rainforest
and your wisdom eye and you say why look
at our Ryan they will say yes it's the
turtle it's a particular set of
constellations on a particular morning
and on that morning
we can imagine that the Sun is rising
and the figures at Bonampak have
convened in order to review the captives
who are being presented to them again
just an example of the crispness of of
the infrared I have to keep showing it
to you because I so loved the high
quality of our amazing line standing
atop the steps here and there are seven
massive steps at the site of Bonampak
where something like this could exactly
be taking place standing at the top of
the steps looking straight out at you is
our king the person who may or may not
be dead in this in the in the bench but
it is kind of interesting to think about
sitting on him and looking up at this
wall at the same time it feels right to
me
yeah how chungmu on who feels who is
standing here with all these captives
presented to him underneath to the right
where I pulled out these figures they
are standing apart they're holding out
their hands their bodies body postures
are extraordinary and if you jump a look
at the doorway you suddenly realize that
there see people seem to be jumping at
the door itself as though it's an
interactive place it's a place where the
next captive could perhaps be taken I
was feeling a little nervous when I
stepped through that door because I know
the explicit threat that I feel and then
if you turn to where you see these two
big round designs that's where the cross
ties went across in the building
stabilizing the vault and subsequently
rotted out here there's a largely
destroyed figure who is holding the
hands of a captive and is pulling out
the fingernails and blood is coursing
down that captives arm his face has
collapsed he may also have lost his
teeth
and then we read across that top step
and these are captives who all their
bodies collapse blood is pouring from
their hands they look up one of them to
the left looks up in a howl scream and
then we come to the figure on the top of
the stairs and that marvelous diagonal
dead captive who draws our attention
we'll come back to the dead captive in
just a moment but in fact this entire
scene is the tableau of one of the Maya
glyphs glyphs words glyphs that
represent speech this is true writing
the word here represented is hoobie
which means to throw down but is being
shown to us also with some logo graphic
elements word picture that are showing
how liquid is streaming from the stars
liquid like blood which is falling here
in this moment it is a tableau let's
come back to the captives and this is a
pre this is an early photograph a
photograph from the 40s in color
photograph this is one of the few areas
that was well-documented
photographically oh it includes
interesting things for art historians
like Pentimento see people changing
where they're where they're going to
paint it but look up look down perhaps
at our dead captive his body is marked
by cuts different places where he has
been a cut perhaps before finally
succumbing to the loss of his heart
blood this is blood which is pouring
down right on to the top of the door and
what we've all when you can see here is
cement that has been used to stabilize
the the doorway covering up part of a
hieroglyph that was never documented
before the cement went in place to
stabilize that door this figure on top
is one of the most poignant there is
blood that is lurking from his fingers
his pate is hanging down and back he
seems to be alive but partly scalped and
we can find him actually this what seems
to be the very same figure being taken
as a captive off in the battle perhaps
this very same individual when we look
at him side by side and it
characteristic of some other Maya
representations as well this is a
stealer that's in the Los Angeles County
Museum of Art which shows a regional
Lord is taking captive and then what's
interesting is that that same captive in
that same Lord turn up on a monument in
the National Museum in Guatemala City
from a more major site as though we see
oh there's a great food chain here
there's a great chain of being captives
taken by one sight turn out to be
captives presented at another and so
that may very well be what's going on
here we're seeing captives taken on the
in the battle they're being presented
keep that thought about who is the
ultimate consumer as we walk out the
door and into room three as we walk out
let me just say that it is actually not
easy to see all of the painting if you
sit on that bench in fact what your eye
encompasses are all those incredibly
beautiful naked captives we know in some
cases that those who are taken in Maya
battle are in fact artists people of
great value who can serve in a new
capacity in a new city and so it's
possible that our captives have been
able to make a painting which fulfills
every requirement of their captors and
yet perhaps they've able been able to
put themselves at the center of a story
and what nothing could be more dreadful
for an artist than to have his hands
damaged
so we step into room three and in our
last few minutes we'll look quickly at
it it's a room that has in fact many
parts of it are only lightly painted and
we have these powerful hot Jaguar solar
deities of the middle of the day over
I'm presiding over the top of the scene
our Maya Lords here are all dressed in
solar costumes including sunflowers the
idea of the sunflower moving and
twisting and look at these dancers
costumes that are all designed for these
twisting images if we looked in the
vault to the upper to the left as we
step in we see a royal family again now
just women without any man present in
the room and to the right we see
musicians but no longer the musical band
of the beautiful but this time the
musical band of a dwarf and others who
seem to have some sort of deformation
and perhaps wear masks of the sort that
I show you here a mask that is out of
the deep pest of Mesoamerica as if to
show times of creation erupting in this
moment of sacrifice the detail and
quality of the painting where we find it
perfectly preserved is still quite
extraordinary with those little stripe
stripe stripes of the restorer added in
and on the throne it's just women
attended by one male servant who are all
drawing blood from their tongues they
are making personal auto sacrifice just
as human sacrifice is going on on the
wall in front of them the under painting
here shows through the sketch of these
lovely voluptuous women the way that it
wasn't meant meant to be seen at the
time but over the over time we can see
how the artist has sketched out their
bodies and then painted atop it the
royal families on the inside here just
as the royal families on the
inside wall in room one as if that's
where you might put a royal family to
preserve them and I show you the three
dancers from room one because they have
reappeared here in room three and
they're the three dancers across the top
and this time they're dancing a
different kind of dance they're dancing
with cart femurs over here on your left
and in the center go out into the
gallery and you'll see that we have a
carved human femur out there here at the
right a handprint bloody handprint on a
fan and then right here in front of you
the pyramid is unfolding we've got so
much activity going on you can hardly
see but this is the scene right in front
of you as you walk into this room is
that there is a captive being dragged
down off the stairs his head missing
where that cement over that area was
never photographed before the cement was
put up and then there microtext
tiny inscriptions right where the air
other arrow is and what did these
inscriptions say well in fact these
inscriptions say and happened in the
land of shield Jaguar the king of yashi
lon
from 26 kilometers away doesn't say
about the 26 kilometers in room 1 it
says the new King took power under the
auspices of the King of yashi lon and in
fact in the doorway of room - of that
incredible battle scene that - said Oh
shows us the king of yashi lon
what's he doing here what's his role we
don't see him portrayed in the paintings
he is never named in these paintings
he's named in one sculpture he's named
in inscriptions what is his role we see
him in fact minor sites around from a
round bone and pock not his at his home
site but we see him receiving captives
he is present
he sits on Thrones he sits on benches
these captives here in this monument at
the Kimball Art Museum are being
delivered up to him
you see these wonderful expressions of
grief and woe they seemed to have and at
the end of the day it does seem that
part of the mission of Bonampak has been
to say at your service
King of yahshua on you wanted music you
want to sit on that bench we'll provide
it to you oh don't mind our little bit
of boredom battle these captives they've
been taken in front of you they've been
taken around you they're being presented
to our King in front of you and you are
the ultimate consumer and this dance
that you see in front of you on these
pair on this pyramid all around the
empty throne the presentation of more
captives it is in fact for you the
absent presence it was a little
disappointing in a way to me at the end
to find that bond and puck is part of
someone else's great chain of being but
in fact perhaps we all are we all live
inside someone else's story and now the
Bonampak story can fit inside the larger
the larger Russian doll of the Maya
story of what is happening around the
Year 800 consolidation on the one hand
extravagant consumption of resources on
the other my gosh all the feathers the
Quetzal feathers Oh
Quetzal as it turns out only grow two
feathers every few years and there are
thousands of them in these paintings all
of it for one great Lord shield Jaguar
yattawan
and what we also learn is that he's
involved in larger Wars larger battles
Arjun narratives in which we are seeing
in some ways the extravagant story of
the end of the Classic Maya as filled
out in these marvelous paintings thank
you